well LeBron James LeBron James who I you
know I'm I have been a fan of as a
basketball player anyway he had remained
conspicuously silent about the whole
China thing up until last night and then
finally he decided to open up and share
some thoughts about it and and listen we
use words like amazing way too often and
and so much so that I think the word is
lost all meaning but his response to the
controversy with China and the NBA and
it really is amazing for a number of
reasons so right off the bat he I want
to play this clip for you of what LeBron
James said last night and it is uh it's
well just just watch we all talked about
this freedom of speech yes we all do
have freedom of speech but at times
there are ramifications for the negative
that can't happen when you're not
thinking about others you know you only
think about yourself so I don't believe
I don't want to get into a work of word
or sentence feud with Darryl with Darryl
more egg but I believe he wasn't
educated on the situation at hand and
any spoke and so many people could have
been harmed not only financially but
physically emotionally spiritually so
just be careful what we what we tweet
and we say and what we do even though
yes we do have freedom speech but there
can be a lot of negative all right
so so there you go now this is sort of
beside the point but what is a he said
he doesn't want to have a word or I
think I heard him right he said he did I
don't want to have a word or sentence
feud with with Darryl more a you know
you don't want to get into a word or
sentence feud daryl morey is the
assistant coach of in houston who
originally sent a tweet supporting the
pro-democracy protesters and in China
but LeBron wants to avoid a word feud so
he doesn't want to play Scrabble with
that with Darryl's what are you saying I
don't even know what that means but
that's not the headline here I suppose
the headline is everything else he said
which we'll get to in just one minute
but first a word from brick house you
know have you ever wondered why so many
Americans
our sick unhealthy overweight it's it's
obviously we heard about all the news
all the time it's obviously one of the
big problems we have in our in our
culture today between the food supply
and a sedentary lifestyle Americans are
in worse shape they've ever been and
that's the truth
that's why the team of on staff
physicians at brickHouse nutrition
created filled that field of greens
field of greens is an easy way for you
to add fruits and vegetables to your
daily routine without spending hours in
the produce section hiring a home chef
taking or taking cheap supplements
writing like that you know and also
there's the expense of now I know
especially for me because we've got kids
and so you want to have produce you want
to have fruit and vegetables and
everything available for everybody but
it's just you spend all that money on
produce and especially we have kids in
the house within 30 minutes it feels
like all the produce you bought is gone
and then you have to go and spend and
mortgage your house again to buy more
produce field of greens solves that
problem field greens is made with real
USDA organic fruits and vegetables it
also helps to boost your immunity using
antioxidants and assist with digestive
help with prebiotics and probiotics it's
like having a doctor and nutritionist
right in your kitchen one scoop delivers
a full serving of fruits and vegetables
you just drop it a cup of water stir it
up and and you're done and that's it
it's also great for smoothies you can
drink it however you want bottom line
this is real food it's not extracts this
is real actual food you will look better
you will feel better go to brick house
Walsh calm and get 15% off your first
order just for trying it out with the
promo code Walsh
that's brick house Walsh calm promo code
Walsh
okay so LeBron while trying to avoid a
word and sentence feud is that why he
was rambling incoherently so as to avoid
forming a complete sentence that way you
don't have a sentence feud I don't know
but LeBron says that coming out in
support of democracy and freedom and
communist China is a sign that you're
not educated he's not educated he hasn't
been educated on the wonders of
communism well he hasn't been
re-educated I suppose is what he what he
means to say any cautions that you know
exercising your free speech
can have ramifications sorry what he
actually said was there are
ramifications for the negative that can
happen as opposed to the Ramakant
ramifications for the positive that can
happen there are ramifications for the
negative that can happen and remember
LeBron James is the one telling the rest
of us to get educated okay
LeBron also says that mores fro pro
freedom stands caused a lot of harm
financial harm of course he was you
mentioned that first because that's what
this is really all about but also
emotional and spiritual harm LeBron is
emotionally and spiritually harmed by
the people in China who don't want to be
oppressed basically what LeBron is
saying is is to those folks is is hey
guys you're really hurting my feelings
here you're really hurting my feelings
why don't you think about me is the
question now I'm trying to sell shoes
over here and you guys are whining about
oppression it's just my might you're
harming my spirit bro my spirit is
totally harmed right now then
LeBron sent some follow-up tweets after
that little powwow with the reporters
and he said here's one of his tweets he
said injustice anywhere is a threat to
justice everywhere okay so it sounds
like he's I guess he's seen the light
and is oh wait no sorry that sorry I I
mistaken that uh
no that's a tweet that he sent last year
okay he sent that last year unrelated to
any of this last year he was saying you
can't have injustice anywhere harms
justice everywhere but he seems to
change his mind I guess on the issue of
injustice he's now before he was he was
anti injustice and now he's sort of Pro
injustice and he's saying hey you know
what injustice isn't so bad hey maybe
there's something to be said for it
injustice is underrated that's his
position now you know here's what LeBron
really tweeted last night he said let me
clear up the confusion I do not believe
there was any consideration for the
consequences and ramifications of the
tweet I'm not discussing the substance
others can talk about that my team and
this league just went through a
difficult week I think people need to
understand what a tweet or statement can
do to others and I believe nobody
stopped it considered what would happen
could have waited a week to send it now
when I first read this you know I read
that first sentence let me clear up the
confusion and and I thought he was going
to do some damage control and kind of
backpedal a little bit where he's saying
okay let me clear up the confusion and
you think okay well now he's gonna but
then no you keep reading and and and oh
my lord he's still complaining about the
tweet dear God
he's still got about this tweet he's it
he's sticking with it and now he wants
us to feel sorry for the NBA because the
league went through a difficult week we
just had a really difficult week you
guys don't understand oh you did LeBron
you had a difficult week well I mean let
me tell you what oppressed the oppressed
citizens of China are going through let
me tell you a little bit about their
week the dictator of China yesterday
said that well the quote-unquote
president of China big big scare quotes
around that he he said that some people
who are trying to separate China ie
those who want to be free he says that
they will quote perish with their body
smashed and bones ground to powder
that's that's a direct quote from from
this guy the great thing is the news of
of that quote that statement from the
dictator of China came out just minutes
after LeBron had had had himself come
out and backed communism in China but
this is what the oppressed masses in
China are dealing with this is their
tough week this is their tough year
their tough life they might get their
bones ground to powder if they try to
resist oppression LeBron on the other
way other on the other hand has been
annoyed by some questions by reporters
so you know it's bones ground to powder
on one hand annoyed by questions on the
other it's a tomato tomahto kind of
situation I suppose but I'll tell you
the thing that that is most amazing
about all this I said it was amazing
here's what's amazing this is really
amazingly LeBrons
statement to reporters his tweets all of
it he he had it's been a week right it's
been a week of this whole discussion so
he had a week he had an entire week to
come up with a tactful intelligent good
ethical response now now it would be
nice if some of these guys would have
some guts and they would have just come
out immediately and and and and put
their foot down and said you know here's
the deal
LeBron didn't want to do that because he
wants to be more diplomatic or some at
least that that's what I assume there's
i way ahead and said anything yet he's
trying to come up with how he's going to
navigate this and you know that's what
you assume and then a week later this is
is what he says this is what he came up
with now you know that he was he must
have sat down with his people over the
last week his PR team and everything and
they were talking about how do you
handle this what do you say that you
know you're the biggest star in the
league everyone's looking to you to see
what you're gonna say let's come up with
something good for you to say something
that kind of walks the line and
everything and so they sat down and this
is what they came up with this for him
to say that of all things so I guess
they said hey you know you should go in
there and and I know what you should say
his team are this is PR team I assume
they said LeBron what you need to do
here's here's here's what we came up
with this is this is why you're paying
us this is why you're paying us six
thousand dollars an hour what you need
to do is is you need to go in and say
that you have been spiritually hurt by
all the calls for freedom in China now
yeah that's what you need to you it's it
spiritually hurts you that's yes that's
it I am I am flabbergasted by that I am
literally flabbergasted I my flabber has
never been so gassed it frankly it's
just I
the it's not just the cowardice okay we
get the cowardice of it it's also just
the being so totally out of touch like
you don't understand how you're coming
across to everybody else
although the cowardice is really the
most disgusting thing of course and you
see that courage is is something that's
just in very short supply in our culture
and a lot of people get credit for being
courageous and taking courageous stands
on things when really there's no courage
involved like we talked about last week
in order for it to be courage okay for
you to take a really courageous stance
means that you're putting something on
the line it means that it means that you
know you are you are potentially
sacrificing something it means that you
are you know you you could lose
something by taking whatever stand
you're taking that's that's courage and
that's why you know for for these guys
to come out and complain about Trump or
whatever that's there's there's no
courage in that now I'm not I have never
been one of those shut up in dribble
types I've never been one of those who
thought that well athletes should never
chime in about politics and should never
give their opinion no I mean these guys
have a platform if they want to use it
if they want to use it to express their
points of view then they can do that
this whole idea that and it kind of
annoys me too sometimes when you've got
people saying to athletes ah shut up and
they stop talking about politics well
you talk about politics
okay whatever your job is I'm sure they
whatever you do for a living I'm sure
you it's it doesn't include talking
politics yet you still talk politics
don't you so they can do it too you know
you can't sit there and tell them to
shut up maybe they could tell you to
shut up how you'd feel about that so
I've never had a problem with that but
all of this the
stuff with China has just exposed how
fraudulent they are you know and you
know this idea that they're gonna use
their plan to use your platform to take
a stand I I'm in favor of that as long
as you do it consistently now you use
your platform to take a stand sometimes
you're gonna take a stand I disagree
with okay it's America we do a free
speech
but now's your chance to use your
platform to take a stand that is really
meaningful and really important and that
will require some courage because yeah
you could lose you could lose
you're gonna lose much okay your life's
not on the line you're still gonna be
rich at the end of it even if you sell
less shoes and even if the NBA loses
some money you're all still gonna be
millionaires at the end of it but yeah
you do you're out you are putting a
little bit on the line and they're not
even willing to do that because when it
comes down to it a lot of people just
are not willing to make any sacrifice
whatsoever
they'll say anything and take any stand
up until the moment when they're
required to make the smallest little
sacrifice and then all of a sudden it's
oh no never mind just completely
disgraceful and shameful across the
board but not surprising in the least
bit okay I don't want to be a broken
record but you know as we talked about
my man Christopher Columbus yesterday my
good buddy Columbus but I had to mention
this predictably statues of Christopher
Columbus or vandalized yesterday on
Columbus Day which I think we all saw
coming and this happened in several
cities around the country here's a let
me give you a show you a shot of of what
they did in Providence here's a picture
of that so they've got red paint all
over the statue with a message that says
stop celebrating genocide now I know
there's no room for actual facts in this
discussion okay when we talk about
Columbus committing genocide I realized
that the people who throw paint on a
statue have probably never read even one
page of one book about this subject okay
I very much doubt that they've sat down
and said let me actually research the
history of Columbus his voyages what
actually happened let me research it for
myself I realize that these people the
kinds of people who would throw paint on
a statue they're getting their
information from Internet means so I
understand that so to try and correct
them in the midst of their hissy fit is
sort of pointless but then again I spend
my life trying to pointlessly correct
stupid people who can't be reasoned with
so why stop now and so I will say no
Columbus did not commit genocide okay
that claim is absurd
on its face it's not true not at all
Columbus was not Jenna Seidel it is it
is it is it is tragically true that a
huge percentage of the native population
died as a result of the European
settlers but almost all of them died by
disease okay and disease brought
accidentally not intentionally and
that's that's an important point here
the disease is now sometimes you'll hear
from people who even think that the
diseases were spread intentionally well
they couldn't have done that even if
they wanted to because back in the you
know the 15th and 16th century people
didn't understand how diseases were
spread in the first place you know
spreading diseases by germs was not
something that people understood it'd be
another 250 300 years before the germ
theory of disease was formulated so to
call the accidental spreading of disease
genocide is just ridiculous ridiculous
and factually inaccurate so it just is
not true now did the Europeans engage in
slavery yes did they did they
intentionally kill people yes were they
violent yes all of that is true but to
say that Christopher Columbus himself
was genocide 'el is just a factually
incorrect statement and that's all there
is to it but what I what I what I keep
having to say about this in general is
yes we can acknowledge and we could
acknowledge that the evil bad things
that were done by people in the past we
can do that and we I think we have done
that I think everyone understands that
the European settlers in some of them
engaged in intra atrocities and horrible
things happened and some of them were
bad people I think we have you know
fully and and probably sufficiently
acknowledge that and I don't think
anyone denies it right so I think I
think that's that's all that's that sort
of been covered okay good
and and and that's fine but we also have
to you know this whole thing of judging
historical people especially people that
lived centuries ago 500 years ago or
more by this by modern standards is so
absurd
and the problem is when you do that if
you're going to do that and this is what
I think people don't understand if you
if you're going to judge historical
people by modern standards then here's
the result
every single person without exception
okay
every single person who existed anywhere
on earth at any point up until about I
don't know 50 years ago will be a bigot
by our standards today if we are taking
modern standards and applying it to
historical but then all of they're not
we have to we have to basically write
off all of them all of our ancestors
doesn't matter where you live what your
race is religion doesn't matter all of
our ancestors we're all scumbags bigots
all of them across the board and that's
that's the conclusion we come to now if
we realize that there's something wrong
with that conclusion you know yes our
ancestors did bad things they had views
that were that were incorrect
we they have views that we find even
reprehensible today if we realize that
but at the same time we say to ourselves
well but we can't what are we gonna say
that the entire world was populated but
there was just nothing good about them
they were all horrible that doesn't make
any sense not only that but that is a
that on top of being an absurd view it's
also incredibly arrogant and egotistical
you know talk about I think what CS
Lewis talked about chronological maybe
that's G K Chesterton one of them one of
those guys talk about chronological
snobbery and and this idea that well
because we're the most recent people to
exist where we are so much better than
everyone who existed before us and
because we can with the benefit of
hindsight we can see their flaws we
can't see our own flaws but we can see
theirs as we look back in time so that's
its chronological snobbery and it's BS
to do that I think we have to come up
with a more nuanced perspective and not
a perspective that excuses things that
were obviously evil and wrong so
Europeans who just slaughtered Native
Americans and that did happen obviously
that's evil and wrong and they knew it
too at the time it's not like people in
history had had no concept of right
versus wrong that's not
point but they did live in a different
time and here are the main things okay
here I here the main differences I think
we have to keep in mind when we look and
analyze events in history the first is
that people who lived a long time ago
they did not have the same compunctions
about violence that we do today now
again as I'm trying to look for a more
nuanced perspective here so you can't my
point is not that every violent thing
they did was fine because they didn't
know they didn't know any better that's
not the point it's just that you know in
our modern society we tend to see
violence as just objectively wrong you
know we say things like violence is
never a way to solve a problem or what
or whatever our ancestors didn't feel
that way that's not how they saw it and
they saw violence as a perfectly
legitimate way to sometimes solve a
problem and I would say that they
weren't necessarily wrong about that now
the violence that that they used you
know in certain situations was wrong so
they applied that incorrectly in in some
cases in many cases but I think that
we're not exactly always correct that
that violence is always on there of
course there are situations where where
violence is okay I think I think you
know maybe our ancestors were or too far
on one end of that spectrum too too
sometimes too eager to settle problems
through violence whereas we've gone too
far in the other direction with this
idea that it's never okay there's never
any situation it's totally wrong all the
time I think that that's that's um that
is a sort of ridiculous view as well but
that's the first thing that's to keep in
mind okay it's it's a it's a cultural
fact they did not quite have the same
compunctions about violence that we do
today the second thing and this is this
is really important is that our
ancestors did not have this concept of
universal human equality we have that
concept today our ancestors did not so
if you had if you had said to someone in
the 14th century for example
all human beings are equal they're all
exactly that they are all worth the same
they're all equal in in moral Worth and
dignity probably doesn't matter who
you're talking to doesn't matter what
country you're in what culture what race
you're saying that to that would have
seemed it wouldn't have meant anything
to them it would have seemed like it
just it would not have processed because
that is a the idea of universal human
equality is very modern
in fact it's so modern think about think
about this that you know all humans are
created equal endowed by their creator
so on and so forth even when that was
written into the Declaration of
Independence as we know it was so far
ahead of its time that the men who came
up with this idea and who wrote that
down they themselves didn't even fully
apply it because of course they still
you know Thomas Jefferson owned slaves
Washington George Washington owned
slaves
so in fact from when that was written to
win it would actually be fully enacted
in our country that was you know that's
like 180 190 years or something it would
be be a very long time from when that
was originally conceived of and written
down to win we actually lived in a
country where everybody was legally
equal so it is a very again it's a very
modern concept and that's just not a
concept that people you know 300 400 500
600 700 years ago had and that's one of
the reasons why slavery was a an
acceptable practiced institution all
across the world and nearly every
culture and civilization they it was
just it was just a way of life it's just
what you did you know in many Indian
cultures you fought a war with another
tribe you beat them you took some of
them as slaves it's just what you did
it's just that's just how it was it's
hard for us to to wrap our heads around
that now or understand that but that's
the fact and so now that we have we live
in a more peaceful time partly because
at least in the West we can afford to be
more peaceful and that's the third
difference so there's actually there's
actually three I think there's the Dean
have the same compunction about violence
didn't have this concept of universal
human equality also they didn't live in
a world that was settled like we do now
you know in our world of course is not
completely settled but it certainly is
more than it has been at any other point
in history they lived at a time where
you know the lines had not been
completely drawn and so people fought
over land it's just happened all across
the globe and if you wanted land that
you didn't have you fought for it it's
just it's that's the way though that's
the way the world worked at the time
which maybe is one of the reasons why
they didn't have that compunction about
violence because they couldn't afford to
and the other thing is if you had land
you realized that you would have to
fight to protect it and you didn't have
you couldn't
time you know feeling sorry for yourself
about that you just you had to fight to
protect what you had and if you couldn't
then you weren't gonna keep it and it's
very easy for us now especially in the
West and it's not like this for
everybody in the world of course but for
us in the West as we live in this
luxurious comfortable world for us you
know we're living this comfortable
lifestyle and we have the benefits now
of hindsight and we we were born into a
world where the truth of for instance
the equal Worth and dignity of all human
beings has been had been passed down to
us and taught to us from childhood we
didn't come up with that we didn't fight
for it we didn't you know we didn't earn
that it was just we were told that from
children so we were born into that world
and it's very easy for us to look back
at our ancestors now and and just write
them all off but I think that's a
mistake to do and even the bad things
that they did I think we have to it's
not excusing it but it is seeing it
within its context alright let's go to
this so Pharrell is on the cover of GQ
and they're calling it the new
masculinity issue and it's all about how
guys like Pharrell are redefining
masculinity here's what the new
masculinity looks like take a look at
this yes the new masculinity looks like
a jacket made for an octopus who is also
a crossing guard that's the new
masculinity a crossing guard octopus and
then here's some more of the new
masculinity some more some more pictures
you see there of what masculinity looks
like now apparently I mean it looks like
he just dove into the clearance bin at
Goodwill and just a random assortment of
ugly clothing that don't fit he looks
like my daughter playing dress-up that's
what especially the one with the with
the huge jack at the huge leopard print
jacket that's the new masculinity the
new masculinity is a six year old girl
playing dress-up
so my six-year-old daughter plays dress
up she is she is now the the example of
masculinity for men everyone
apparently now again I know there's no
point as I said in introducing logic
into into this discussion but I can't
help but point out that these efforts to
redefine masculinity make no sense in
light of the fact that the very concept
of manhood is supposedly subjective and
effectively meaningless now if it
doesn't really mean anything to be a man
then what's the point of coming up with
a new masculinity in other words in
order for a biological female to
identify as a man which is a thing now
that she can do doesn't manhood then
have to be masculine in order for that
to make sense isn't the whole damn point
of identifying as a man you know it
isn't at the whole point of it isn't
that effectively what you're saying
in other words aren't you basically
saying you say identify as a man what
you're really saying is I identify as a
masculine person if masculinity is now
feminine then what does it mean for a
woman to identify as a man so she
identifies as a man but men are like
women so she identifies as a man who's
essentially a woman she's a man who's a
woman who's a man who's a woman it just
doesn't make sense so in this is the
problem that's the contradiction the
whole concept of identifying as a man or
identifying as a woman depends on those
things being distinct and defined you
know it really depends on men being
masculine and women being feminine but
if we're tearing down masculinity and
femininity then everyone might as well
stay their own genders because we're all
just sort of meeting in the middle
anyway right we're all just getting
together meeting in the middle swapping
clothes and it's a free-for-all and then
in that case if everything is fluid and
it's all sort of a it's whatever you're
a woman you're then then okay if that's
what it is
you kind of have to choose is the point
you have to we're either doing that or
we're doing a thing where you know it
being a man is something objective and
definable and and but sometimes a woman
could identify as one and you know so
you could you could do one of the other
but you can't really do both or here's a
better idea we could do neither of those
things and just men are men women or
women and you're never gonna cross from
one to the other that's also an option
all right uh let's go to let's go to
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com this is from
Stephen says hey Matt my name is Stephen
and my parents spanked me growing up I'm
20 and don't have kids yet so I'd like
to point out that I contradict the case
you had explained yesterday where people
think fondly on their spankings because
they spanked their own kids as a kid I
hated spankings I was far more deviant
than my siblings and got significantly
more spankings because of it however I'm
grateful that my parents spanked because
it did teach me discipline and
ultimately taught me to respect my
father in a way that I don't know I
would have if they used other
disciplinary methods my parents also
never hit out of anger if I was in
trouble they'd send me to my room and
before they spanked they'd go pray in
their room to make sure they were making
the right decision and then they talked
through with what I did wrong and
afterwards they'd have me pray for
forgiveness
I may be an outlier in that my parents
never once hit me out of anger but I
just thought your argument didn't take
into perspective and experience like
mine where I don't look back fondly but
but could easily be misunderstood as
such yeah well that's night I think my
my argument did take into account
exactly your situation Stephen that's
what I was saying is that I think that
although although we don't spank our
kids it's not we just decide that's not
right for our family I think if you're
if you are as a parent doing it not out
of anger not because you're unleashing
your frustration not because you're just
pissed off but you're doing it you know
you're taking as I said kind of a
businesslike approach and this is also
important which I didn't talk about
yesterday but that you have spanking as
a penalty for certain things and the
child knows ahead of time that that is
the penalty for that thing whatever it
is okay and then in that case then that
takes the anger out of it even more it's
just okay you that was a penalty you did
it now here's here's the punishment and
they they might not like it as a kid but
at some level they understand that okay
I did this thing and that's the penalty
so if spam
being approached that way then I think
it's it's it can be a perfectly valid
and effective form of discipline and
certainly not abuse I disagree with the
people who say that all forms of
spanking are abuse I just I don't I I
think that that's silly even I don't
agree with that
my only so that's that's fine Steve it
sounds like your your situation was what
we're talking about here valid form of
discipline I just wonder of all the
parents who do spank their kids and of
course any parent you talk to they're
gonna say that they never spank an anger
and you know I don't think any parents
gonna come out as Ellie I hit my kid all
the time because I'm because I'm ticked
off no parents gonna say that but I do
wonder of all the parents who spank
their kids as a form of discipline what
percentage of them do it sometimes or
even regularly out of anger and I
suspect that it's probably a rather
large percentage and in the case of
those parents they are physically
abusing their kids they may not feel
like it you know I you never want to
stop and say to yourself oh my gosh I am
a physical abuser of my children but
they are you know and I'm not saying a
parent who one time spanked their kid
out of anger I'm not saying that they
are terrible parent and they should lose
their kids you know or their kids are
ruined for life right I'm not saying
that I'm just but it is a serious that's
a serious issue
[Music]
that's a line that you just never want
to cross okay this is uh let's see here
this is from Steve says Matt really
enjoy your show and everything on Daily
wires Shapiro brings intellect to bear
Clavin humor and you a lot of heart and
a lot of dad okay so I don't have
intellect or humor I have heart that
Rhett feels like Steve I I know you
meant that as a comment it feels like a
backhanded compliment a little bit Hey
it appears a smart one claims really
funny you got heart you put in the
effort kid you're doing well no I
appreciate it though thank you this is
not so much a question for the mailbag
as it is a comment on one of today's
questions specifically the one regarding
priestly celibacy as a convert to
Catholicism from evangelical
Protestantism I had similar views
regarding celibacy to me it seemed too
much of a burden to be placed on men
that might otherwise have chosen the
vocation since then my opinions have
become more nuanced I will certainly
agree that allowing priests to marry
won't solve the pedophilia problem
pedophiles are attracted to any
situation where they have Authority
trust and privacy with young boys Scout
leaders athletic Coaches church youth
group leaders these are all fertile
fields for pedophiles but you make the
case that desired have a family is a
noble and natural thing and that
priestly celibacy is an unnecessary
denial of those basic and good instincts
what I have come to believe however is
that celibacy is not a burden it is a
grace that God grants those called to
the priesthood
the Apostle Paul even says that it would
be better for his followers if they were
more like him celibate but it is better
to marry than to burn with lust Ison he
makes it clear that a married man cares
for the needs of his family but a
celibate priest is free to take care of
the things of God after all Christianity
is a religion of self-denial Jesus tells
us that if we were to follow him we must
deny ourselves and take up our cross but
a priest is called to celibacy is a gift
and an opportunity to mortify the flesh
in the service of a higher spiritual
goal in spite of the paucity of
vocations I would rather have fewer
committed priests than lower the bar to
get the numbers up I think that's a
perfectly valid argument that certainly
is the argument in favor of it I think
you eloquently expressed it and I think
it's a powerful argument in many ways
and I see I can I I see it from I can
see that perspective it that's the
perspective that I had
I just I just there are two things after
we have taken account one is the reality
of the situation so we could say yeah it
would it's great if priests can carry
this cross and and and exhibit this kind
of self-control and on top of all the
other benefits now the thing about you
know if you're a priest if you're a
pastor
you've got your flock that's really a
full-time job and so if you've got your
own family then of course your family
has to come first you have to put your
flock second one of the advantages of
having celibate priests is that you
focus a hundred percent on your on your
priestly duties and I think that's a
that's a that's maybe the in some even
though even though that's the practical
argument I think maybe that's the best
argument for priestly celibacy because
it's a it's you know you talked to
people and process denominations for
example and they'll tell you that this
is that can be a real problem and this
is why it's a real issue in some
Protestant churches Protestant churches
where the pastors you know they have
problems in their own families and with
their marriages because they're being
torn by these two demands and so I think
that practically speaking that's a very
good reason to have celibate priests but
again now we run up against the reality
and the reality is that a very large
percent I don't know what the percentage
is but it's clear that a very large
percentage of priests are simply not
living up to that and so do we just
charge on ahead and say yeah you know
whether they'll figure it out eventually
or do we say maybe it's time to consider
making a change and then the other part
of it is like I said yesterday I really
feel like the desire to have a family
and have a wife is good and natural and
Noble I don't think it's any lesser I
don't think it's a lesser vocation than
celibacy at all I think that they're
just
and there's a place for both I suppose
but we are ruling out as I said
yesterday you that the Catholic Church
is excluding is in principle ruling out
men who have a very strong healthy
natural and noble desire to have a wife
and a family that that is a whole
category of men that we're saying nope
you're we're on the place for you and
the priesthood and I'm just wondering if
that's in the end a good strategy I
think maybe it's not I think maybe those
men have something to offer even though
there are those very real practical
difficulties as I mentioned I still
think those men have something to offer
and and maybe we should welcome them but
there are you know there's there's a I
still I'm a little torn on it I guess as
you can see from Carly this is I met I
have a simple question what is your new
daughter's name I don't think you've
mentioned it well thank you Carly for
asking that question
funny story actually our daughters name
as it stands right now is Emma grace
okay first first name Emma grace but
here's the great thing
all through my wife's pregnancy okay we
debated this and I liked Emma as the
first name grace as the middle my wife
wanted Emma Grace as the whole first
name like to do a to name first name
deal and I told her again and again
again I made the point that if we do
that we're gonna have to spend our whole
lives clarifying to everyone that Emma
Grace is her first name you know one
it's the whole first name two names not
first in the middle for to name first
and every time we're at an appointment
where anywhere you know someone asks us
her name every time we're gonna have to
go they're gonna say what's her name or
say Emma grace is that first in middle
or no first name is that one word or two
two words capital e and g yeah you kept
it's on our whole lives and her whole
life we're gonna have to have this
conversation over it over and over and
over again
millions of times literally
we will have consigned her to a life of
explaining her name to people and that
is there are some people who live a life
like that and if you have a name you
know if you have a name that's confusing
confusing spelling whatever ever any
whatever reason you know what it's like
you your whole life you have to explain
your name and that is the life of a -
named person she will wander the
countryside ostracized abandoned by
society while people point their fingers
at her and say here comes the - name get
out here - name her
no two names allowed I mean that's
what's gonna happen and my wife said
I'll stop it'll be fine
well guess what a week after she was
born a week after she was born a week
seven days my wife came to me and said
man this is really getting annoying
after having to explain the name thing
to people and I said ha I told you so
I told you this is this is the greatest
i-told-you-so moment of my life this is
amazing because that we're gonna have to
change her name now legally a week after
after she was born it because and this
is this is amazing
I get this but of course my wife tries
to act like like I hadn't been arguing
this whole day when she came to me and
said oh this is getting annoying she
didn't say she didn't preface it with oh
you turns out you were right she just
she said it as if as if no one had
brought this up before trying to
underplay which I understand okay
because she can't let me have this I
told you so a moment it's too good it's
just strategically in a marriage you
can't let your spouse have one like this
because you're always looking for the I
told you so which is a healthy thing to
do in a marriage by the way it's a
little competition people always say
I'll never say I told you so
I disagree it's just it's it you got to
keep the competitive spirit alive in a
marriage I think it's a little bit of
the chess match that goes on and so you
know you stack your chips and now I'm
mixing metaphors but you get it so
anyway but so she doesn't want to give
it to me but we are going to have to
officially change her name I think we
are going to change so it was Emma grace
first name we're going to officially
change it so - and make it so grace is
the middle name
and and no matter how my wife tries
downplay it the fact remains that for
the rest of our lives I will have this
story about the week that our daughter
spent with a different name than the one
she ended up with and how it was changed
because I was right and I told you so we
might as well change her name to I think
her middle name should be I told you so
Emma I told you so Walsh that's my I
think that's what I'm gonna do that's
gonna be her name now so this is a it's
faint but I'm really happy about it it's
just you know especially look everyone
knows not to be stereotypical but but in
a marriage the the husband doesn't get
as many of the I told you so's so when
you get one as a husband you got to grab
onto that one just don't let it go okay
not saying you throw it in her face all
the time
just put it in put it in a put it in a
satchel and just kind of keep it in the
closet somewhere just nice and safe
maybe store it store it in a safe
actually a lockbox and every once in a
while when you need to pull it out you
pull it out you just say see don't
remember the I told you so all right
that's my don't take my marriage advice
folks don't take it I will we'll leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena Matt Walsh
show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are depressed because the American
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]